(audience applauding)
- So here's something
that I'm obsessed with,
and I wrote this in
your card in your room,
but I've never had my palm read.
- And you had your palm
read in New Orleans.
- I did, I did.
- And here's the best part, like,
tell them about the story,
because I love when you go back.
- Okay.
So one of my producers from
another show called me,
he was following me on
Instagram, and said,
"Hey, I see you're in New
Orleans, you should check out this
palm reader and tarot card reader."
And I go, "I'm not (scoffs) what?
No, I'm not doing that,
this is ridiculous, no."
I happened to have some time to kill.
I had about a half hour
or an hour and I said,
"Okay, well, I'm in the area,
I'll go in the French Quarter
and I'll check it out."
I go in, I'm like, "I'm not
gonna tell her anything.
Stone poker-faced, not
gonna give her anything.
I'm so not into this, I'm
pretty sure she's full of it.
Let me see if I can just
find out what's going on."
(audience laughs)
- I am so you.
- I'm so like,
- I'd wanna throw them off.
- "Whatever," I'm like, "Yeah, right."
- They're like "Do you like bananas?"
I don't know.
- Yeah, like no.
- What do you think?
Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know.
- Exactly, I don't eat, what do you want,
what do you want?
- I'm not sure.
(laughing)
- And I sat there and she, you know,
I did tarot cards, she
did the whole thing,
and I'm about 10 minutes in, I'm going,
"Okay (surprised stammers)"
And by the time it was over, I was like,
"It's over?"
I was like, "I need more."
She was like "I have another appointment".
I go, "Well are you available
in another half hour
because I need to talk to you some more."
And I went to the bar like two doors down,
I decided to drink a beer, and I'm like,
"I gotta go back and talk to her."
She had me, and I was
trying so hard, she had me.
I'm sorry, guys, I'm a sucker.
- Okay.
I feel like I'm a sucker too, but, like,
I kinda think that some people are
extremely intuitive and
can, like, read stuff.
- It's in the cards, I mean, look.
It's a specific thing the
cards are supposed to say,
and they have specific meanings.
Yeah, some of them could be
generic, but when you sit there,
you know what's going on in your life,
and if it's true, what are you gonna do?
Lie about it?
If it's true, you're gonna go,
"Okay, that makes sense,
can I find out more?"
Because she'll ask you
"Does this speak to you?"
What, are you gonna lie?
It's speaking to me.
Yeah, I want that card,
I wanna talk about that.
It's just one of those things.
- Oh my gosh, I wanna do it so badly.
- Trust me, I'm gonna give you her name.
I'm gonna find out (drowned
out), I'll get in contact.
- We should do, like, a
piece where we both go again.
Will you do it with me?
- Yeah, we should do it.
Yes, Kelly Clarkson in New Orleans.
We can do the food!
- I love New Orleans!